Greetings,
earth,
enthusiastic garrick's were ameloid here
to inform you that my series on the
study and appreciation of ancient earth
culture will be moving to a new channel.
The Museum of Earth studies not only
were like,
continue to analyze earthling cinema,
but I'll also analyze other cultural
artifacts such as movie pass,
Tama got cheese and something called
farmers only.
So to continue to enrich your lives by
learning about this cosmic fart of a
civilization,
follow me over to my new channel by
clicking the link in the description.
In the meantime,
please enjoy my rendition of this
intergalactic chart topper,
which you may find a little familiar,
right?
Yeah.